[Music]
watch out re coulton is coming for the
kissing bandit title the 26 year old
former football star Colton Underwood
made his lip-locking debut as The
Bachelor on Monday night and although
there was plenty of virgin talk as we
expected there was also a lot of
lip-locking
kissing a villain also emerged on night
one of the reality show Catherine but
she came with a dog so could she really
be that bad
one woman dressed in a full sloth
costume you're stating character the
whole time are you committed to it I can
respect that and Colton gave out his
first impression rose - Hanna G there's
definitely a chemistry and a nice spark
with Hanna Hanna former bachelors and
bachelorettes made cameos giving Colton
their words of encouragement
I think Colton is ready to have
something like we have you know marriage
and babies and I think he deserves to
find someone amazing I call them this is
your future man
et recently sat down with him where he
dished on his strategy when it came to
dating 30 women I did things my way and
I changed the game but nothing can
prepare you for this I don't
is it normal to date 30 women at one
time I don't know well you tell me no
it's not how are you still a virgin
would you want me to spoil that for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]